what's the best advice you have on
raising a daughter when you get square
little there was a rule the rule was we
do not want to expose our children to
social contempt and disapproval act in a
way that the people around you will
approve of when we used to take you to
restaurants people would come over after
we were done eating and tell you and
Julian how well you behaved and how
happy they were to see that and they
were smiling and that's way better I've
gone out with people there two-year-old
kid with them and then just kid runs all
over the restaurant just causing trouble
Non-Stop and everybody in the restaurant
they're not happy and the parents think
well yeah I want to interfere with his
creative freedom and then they refused
to notice that they're exposing their
child to social contempt